Xbox game pass is so much more than a
catalog of games you can play it's the
foundation for where Microsoft believes
gaming is headed in the future and
whether or not Microsoft is successful
in the next-gen mic depend more on game
paths than sales of the series X and
here's why
Microsoft's bold new vision for the
future of gaming is rooted in its past
Microsoft came up short against Sony in
terms of current gen console sales some
estimates state that the ps4 outsold the
Xbox one by a two-to-one margin the Xbox
one could never fully recover from its
initial launch struggles but now
Microsoft is putting itself in a very
strong position as it heads into the
Xbox series X era and Beyond in a way
that might completely change the way you
play games selling a lot of consoles is
good of course but the real money in
games comes from software and services
Xbox boss Phil Spencer told The Verge
last year the business isn't how many
consoles you sell the business is how
many players are playing the games that
they buy and how they play I think it's
easy from the outside to judge the
health of our business around how many
consoles any company sells in the end
how many subscribers you have to
something like game paths
how many games people are buying those
are the much better metrics on the
health of the business of course Spencer
would say this because Microsoft got
handily beaten by PlayStation in the
last gen but Spencer is not just in car
salesman mode here game consoles are
historically sold at a loss and this
trend is expected to continue for both
Microsoft and Sony with the next
generation the future of gaming is about
establishing a wide install base of
users and creating an ecosystem where
people can connect and play together no
matter what platform they choose to play
on in this business model Xbox game pass
is key Phil Spencer has claimed that
Microsoft is intent on reaching the two
billion gamers in the world that's an
impossible goal if the requirement is
for people to own a game console but you
can reach an audience that is factors
bigger than the current market of
console owners by making games available
where the audience is and that's
everywhere
Xbox game pass allows for this
especially with X cloud scheduled to be
integrated into the service later this
year once X cloud becomes folded into
game pass Microsoft will edge closer to
creating the elusive and potentially
lucrative Netflix of games currently
Xbox game past subscribers must download
their games and with file sizes for some
larger games stretching beyond a hundred
gigabytes and possibly growing even
larger in the next generation this can
be a long and laborious process
integrating X cloud will let you stream
a service already available on console
mobile phones and PC increasing the
addressable market for Xbox Microsoft
still wants to sell you a console and
for the next 10 years or so that will
most likely remain the best and most
reliable way to play games it may always
be the preferred way for some to play
games but Microsoft is preparing for a
future where it's not the only way the
key metric to success for Xbox in this
new world is your xbox live subscription
and not necessarily the number of
consoles sold an Xbox Live Gold user is
either paying Microsoft ten dollars a
month or $60 a year which is the kind of
steady recurring revenue that any
business wants to see every person on
earth who owns a connected device a
phone a tablet a PC or a console is a
potential Xbox Live user Spencer's new
vision for Xbox is making a run at
bringing you into the fold an Xbox game
pass is central to that goal Xbox game
pass is only worth it if Microsoft has a
steady flow of games to support it and
to that end Microsoft is bigger than
it's ever been in terms of its game
development footprint the company now
operates 15 internal studios as part of
its Xbox game studios label all of which
are working on next-gen projects if
Microsoft can successfully line up
production pipelines and schedule
releases from its internal teams
not to mention third parties it could
create a Netflix type scenario where
there is always something new on the
horizon so far Microsoft has announced
that halo Infinite will release on Xbox
game paths as well as all future gears
Forza fable games obsidians new title
grounded ninja theories hell-blade
sequel and rares new IP ever wild
Microsoft has no doubt spent a pretty
penny to buy these studios and invest in
their projects but you got to spend
money to make money
perhaps the most exciting part about
Xbox game paths is
could lead to new and creative games
from teams we might not have otherwise
heard about like Netflix which is green
lighting and funding the kinds of TV
shows and movies that traditional
studios might not take on Xbox game
passes seemingly setting up something
similar a developer can launch their
game into Xbox game paths with the
understanding that the built-in audience
from day one is already million-strong
even if you're keen for Microsoft's
vision for the future of gaming there
are still some lingering questions I
wonder if subscription services like
Xbox game paths will end up devaluing
games in the long run and if so if
that's a problem for Microsoft or
developers to bear the latest GDC state
of the industry survey showed that more
than a quarter of surveyed developers
believe a subscription model erodes the
value of a game devolver digital
co-founder Graham Struthers tells
GameSpot the world of subscription is a
worry you do wonder if it's going to
lead to a situation where there is so
much content that you kind of fall off
the edge that's the one that keeps us up
at night there is also the concern of
further ceding ownership of your games
to a monolithic company that can change
its policies whenever it pleases to
achieve whatever goals it has that have
nothing to do with you
all in all there has never been a game
subscription program as ambitious as
Xbox game pass and if it gains traction
it could very well change the way you
play games would Microsoft have pursued
such an ambitious strategy have the
roles been reversed and Xbox came out on
top in the last generation we can never
know but one thing's for sure this feels
like a watershed moment in gaming and
that's really exciting at the start of a
new console generation
you
[Music]